with the biggest retail season of the
year nearly upon us one major retailer
unveiled a huge innovation this week
Lowe's is testing out robotic shopping
assistance at one of its smaller
hardware stores
hello I am mosh bought the orchard store
robot helper what are you looking for
today where can I find more of these is
this the item you are looking for yes
I'll take you yes
Lowe's is introducing robot sales
assistants to one of their stores which
might seem like a good idea but brace
yourself Lowe's because you may be about
to get a lot of sexual harassment
lawsuits from your refrigerators well
although going by their promotional
video at least someone seems to be a fan
I actually really liked it and we could
be considered friends okay stop stop
stop stop it because the sentence the
customer service robot at Lowe's is my
friend may be the single saddest
sentiment ever spoken out loud robot
assistants are a terrible idea and
here's why
sales associates and home improvement
stores are not there to help people find
things they're there to stop couples
from tearing each other apart if you
really want to test your marriage go buy
home supplies together because Lowe's is
like a swingers party or a couple's
brunch
no one is leaving on speaking terms and
the worst thing is Lowe's knows this
look at their own ads we went to Lowe's
just for some light bulbs a little bit
distracted they were looking at light
bulbs but I had a feeling they were
interested in some things for the patio
can I help you with something for the
patio yes nicely done Loisel I was
employee yet you sensed an explosive
argument was coming and you diffused it
with the emotional anesthetic of patio
furniture robots can't do that they
don't realize that home-improvement
stores are a lethal combination of
everything that can ruin a relationship
spending money reconciling tastes
long-term planning and fluorescent
lighting in fact if I was Home Depot and
I heard that Lowe's were replacing
humans with robots this is the
that I would be running at Home Depot we
valued the personal touch
sure Lowe's may have robots but we know
there are some things machines can do
we came to Home Depot to renovate our
kitchen and things got a little heated
he had his heart set on this copper sink
guilty
they started bickering but I had a
feeling it wasn't about the copper sink
it never is about the coppers are you
fighting me on this it has a ten year
warranty oh I'm sorry are we gonna be in
this house for ten more years where else
are we gonna go in a house big enough
for the second child you promised me we
were gonna have if I could just butt in
here there is a lot to be said for a
hammered finish copper sink it adds a
lot of warmth to any room and copper is
naturally easy to maintain plus it is
just a sink it is just the same yeah you
guys like Glade plugins Oh check this
out Doug was great
he gave us advice right when we needed
it right before one of us says something
we could never take back hey lip this is
nice mama would love it
why doesn't matter what plants your
mother would like for when she moves in
with us no I am not having this
discussion again oh boy I told you again
and again I'm not putting her in a home
ever she raised me yes you and your
deadbeat brother that's your argument
every time you bring up Devlin
he's trying it's hard to get a job when
they have to do background jets you
should stick with the Boston fern on
this one the eucalyptus is for koalas
and pacifists now if you want I can show
you some of our selection of floor
plants oh my god yes he talked to us
about floor plans for five solid minutes
until both of us forgot we were fighting
about that's what we do here hey I
really like this bamboo floor of course
you do he loves everything Asian
especially the girls he looks at on his
porn excuse me
clear your history Ben you're not the
only one who uses that iPad Mini that's
someone's daughter what her daughter
were Asian how would our daughter be
Asian
we could've job if you weren't so
selfish okay so if you're asking me if I
want a my hypothetical Asian daughter
the answer is no Home Depot I don't want
to Keynesian forget about the bamboo
sure it's good with the humidity but
wood flooring is barely better than a
carpet when it comes to a bathroom let
me show you some ceramic tiles I think
you'll both agree on hey yeah let's do
it
Doug was great and the bathroom is
beautiful so you don't wish we'd gotten
that copper sink not as much as I wish
you hadn't given a hand job to my best
man on our wedding day the only one how
many hand job did you give up right okay
great let's do two three well sales
let's take a look at some paint swatches
and think about freshening up that
kitchen what if you take a spring grass
lay it right in here on tournament field
let's talk backsplash
[Music]
[Applause]